wer bin ich
die frage nach der eigenen identität
kann menschen mit behinderung genauso
umtreiben wie im kubanischen film el
khadra so einem der filme die am
diesjährigen kurzfilmfestival locken
soll gezeigt werden
elena wähle ist stammgast am festival
sie lebt in berlin und unterrichtet
physik und mathematik seit geburt hat
sie eine spastische lähmung im
niederländischen film alles ist gesagt
verliert ein vater seine alte identität
durch einen herzinfarkt
dank respekt nähe und humor seines
umfelds findet er eine neue balance
zwischen abhängigkeit und
selbstbestimmung dreimal war elena viele
schon in der lotterie
sie findet ein guter film über
behinderung soll vor allem klischees
vermeiden aspekt aber auch sticht ihn
wir sind dann natürlich auch ist die
geschichte irgendwie entsprechend
spannend sind die filmischen mittel
schön und einfach gemacht
der filmstar hat den diesjährigen oscar
für den besten kurzfilm gewonnen und
läuft ebenfalls am festival eher
schüchtern der kassen greenwood lernt
die gebärdensprache weil er sich für
sein stottern schämt der regisseur von
benjamin klebt in dublin
die motivation für den film entsprang
seiner jugend freundschaft mit einem
stotterer dessen alltäglicher kampf in
stark beeindruckte den großteil meiner
recherche habe ich online betrieben
ich stieß auf unzählige youtube videos
von diesen unglaublich tapferen menschen
die erzählen wie es sich anfühlt ein
stotterer zu sein die von ihren kleinen
siegen und schwierigkeiten im alltag
berichten im film tauscht sich carsten
seit einem halben jahr online mit elli
aus als jedoch ein treffen vorschlägt
will er einen rückzieher machen
eine person mit behinderung muss sich
nicht zwangsläufig darüber definieren
die menschen realisieren das oft gar
nicht und sehen nur die behinderung
es hat mich fasziniert empfehlen dieses
reiche aber verborgene innenleben sicht
und hörbar zu machen kassen akzeptiert
schließlich den stadtrat in sich und
erlebt am ende eine freudige
überraschung
doch in der heutigen optimierungs
gesellschaft drohen menschen mit
behinderung verdrängt zu werden
die filmkunst kann hier gegensteuer
geben die man sich selber erkennen in
der auseinandersetzung mit dem gegenüber
diese chance bietet das kurzfilmfestival
logcontrol nur wenn man genau hinschaut
kommen die dinge ins rollen